esto que ves aquí en azul es la gráfica
de ye igual a efe de x donde fx es la
función x al cubo menos 6 x al cuadrado
más x menos 5
lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es encontrar cuál es la ecuación de la
recta tangente a esta función cuando x
es igual a 1 y lo podemos visualizar
bastante bien aquí por aquí está x igual
a 1 y cuando x es igual a 1 la función f
toma este valor este valor de aquí y la
recta tangente a la función f en este
punto se va a ver más o menos
puedo dibujar lo mejor la recta tangente
se va a ver más o menos así pero a ver
lo que nosotros queremos es encontrar la
ecuación de esta recta y si estás muy
inspirado y ojalá que si lo estés ponle
una pausa al vídeo y encuentra esta
ecuación por tu cuenta
bueno para resolver esto algo que
podemos hacer es encontrar la derivada
de la función f en este punto porque la
derivada justo es la pendiente de la
recta tangente y entonces si ya sabemos
cuál es la pendiente de la recta
tangente y además conocemos un punto que
pertenece a esa recta entonces ya
podemos encontrar la ecuación de esa
recta al fin es que queremos encontrar
la ecuación de la recta tangente a efe
cuando x es igual a 1 bueno pero
empecemos evaluando
efe de uno efe de uno es igual a uno
elevado a la potencia 3 que es
simplemente un 1
- 6 por 1 elevado a la potencia 2 pero
eso es simplemente menos 6 menos 6 y
luego más uno más uno menos 5 menos 5 y
esto a cuánto es igual es igual a 2
menos 11 o sea menos 9 y eso se ve bien
no por aquí esto sí parece ser menos 9
por cierto la escala del eje y es
distinta a la escala del eje x así es
que f 1 es menos 9 a ver si como sí lo
hice bien uno menos 6 es menos cinco más
uno menos cuatro menos cinco si lo hice
bien menos nueve y ahora vamos a ver
cuánto es la derivada de f en uno pero
para eso sería bueno primero encontrar f
prima de x cierto pero bueno este es un
polinomio para encontrar su derivada
simplemente tenemos que utilizar la
regla de las potencias
por aquí tenemos x elevada a la potencia
así es que tomamos el 3 lo multiplicamos
por el coeficiente nos queda 3 y
multiplicamos por la equis pero ahora
elevada a la potencia que tenía menos
uno y tres menos uno es 2 entonces
tenemos 3 por x elevada a la potencia 2
y luego tenemos menos 6 por x a la 2
tomamos el exponente lo multiplicamos
por el coeficiente menos 6 por 2 es
menos 12
x a la 2 - 1 pero dos menos uno es uno
que lo podemos dejar simplemente así más
la derivada de x que es simplemente un 1
ahora si lo queremos ver paso por paso
por aquí está x es igual a tomar la
equis y elevarla a la potencia 1
entonces tomamos el exponente 1 lo
multiplicamos por el coeficiente que
también es 1 nos sigue quedando uno y
luego multiplicamos por x elevada a la
potencia que tenía menos 1 o sea que nos
queda x a la cero pero x a la cero
también es 1 y luego la derivada de una
constante es simplemente cero entonces
esta es la derivada de la función f y si
queremos evaluarla en uno lo que nos
queda es f prima evaluada en uno igual a
tres por uno al cuadrado que es
simplemente un 3 menos 12 por 1 nos
queda menos doce más uno
y ahora 312 es menos nueve más uno es
igual a menos ocho y entonces lo que
acabamos de obtener aquí es la pendiente
de esta recta la recta tangente a la
gráfica en este punto la pendiente de
esta recta es menos 8 y también
conocemos un punto de esa recta este
punto de aquí que es x igual a 1 y es
menos 9 y con esta información ya
podemos encontrar la ecuación de la
recta las ecuaciones de las rectas como
seguramente te acuerdas tienen esta
forma ye igual a m x + b donde m es la
pendiente de la recta así es que ya
sabemos que ya es igual menos 8 x x más
y ahora solo nos falta encontrar ave
pero para encontrarla podemos sustituir
los valores de xy de algún punto que
sabemos que pertenece a la recta y aquí
tenemos ese punto entonces en esta recta
sigue es igual a menos 9 ok y es igual a
menos 9 x tiene que ser igual a 1 y lo
que obtenemos aquí es que menos 9 es
igual al menos 8 por 1 o sea menos 8 más
b y ahora sí ya casi encontramos a b
podemos simplemente sumar 8 de los dos
lados y lo que nos queda es que menos 1
es igual a b y listo ya terminamos ya
encontramos la ecuación de esta recta
tangente de esta recta color magenta que
es igual a la pendiente de la recta
28 x x + b pero ve ya encontramos que es
igual a menos uno menos uno por cierto
ve es la intersección de la recta con el
eje x